welcome to the show friends neighbors
chums cronies on this blessed Ash
Wednesday today will will run down and
review the democratic debate which
happened last night and in many ways and
for many reasons it was an embarrassment
as it always is for the Democratic Party
but but that fortunately makes it
hilarious for everybody else hilarious
until you remember that these people
want to control the country and then it
becomes sad so it's a you know
embarrassing hilarious said it's kind of
a roller coaster emotional journey when
you watch these debates also speaking of
the Democratic Party in embarrassments
they yesterday blocked a bill that would
have prevented clinics and hospitals
from leaving babies born after botched
abortions to die the the bill would have
guaranteed those those born children at
least basic medical care while Democrats
blocked that and said no it's better to
just let the children die so we have to
talk about that as the Democratic Party
again reveals itself to be the party of
evil we'll discuss that also five other
news headlines worth knowing about Plus
today I have the distinct honor of
cancelling The New Yorker I'm going to
officially canceled in New York oh and
I'll explain why first a reminder that
my book Church of cowards officially
went on sale yesterday you could get it
now the response to the book so far has
been has been very encouraging and I
appreciate everyone who's bought the
book so far and reached out to me about
it if I were to sum up the point of the
book in three sentences or less well I
guess the point is really just right
there in the title this is about a
wake-up call to complacent Christians
but really what I'm calling for in the
book is for the revival of
Christianity's fighting spirit because
ours is a warrior faith or at least
that's what it's supposed to be that's
what it has been historically that's our
that's our heritage and and and you know
maybe we are not called to a physical
fight at least in this rate region of
the world these days but we are called
to a spiritual fight a moral fight we
can't shrink away from that and we have
been though for many decades now and
that's why I wrote the book and that was
more than three sentences I suppose but
you can go to Amazon and buy it now so
please do that all right
debate last night
I suppose on this day of repentance it
makes sense to start with the democratic
debate as watching it for me was an act
of penance overall impressions right out
of the gate a rather catastrophic night
for the Democratic Party let's begin
with the optics okay let's think about
this this is a debate for the Democratic
nomination and that is supposed to be
we're told the Progressive Party the
enlightened party the party of inclusion
the party of diversity well who was on
stage last night two billionaires two
billionaires not just one two in the
democratic debate three millionaires
three men over 70 only one person under
fifty all white people no minorities
that was the debate so old white folks
almost exclusively that's and mostly men
so that's what the Democratic Party has
to offer their field is at this point
what they accuse the Republican Party of
being that's exactly what they are other
impressions first of all Bernie Sanders
and Joe Biden it concerns me that every
time I watch one of these debates all
right I watch them giving a speech for
as long as I can tolerate it what what
what it seems clear to me that they are
not capable of saying anything or
answering any question without screaming
everything they say have you noticed
that everything they say they're
screaming I'm not sure I've ever heard
either one of them say anything in a
normal inside voice so I was imagining
last night like how it must sound when
when Biden goes to like order a pizza at
Pizza Hut you know the guy says hi
welcome to Pizza Hut can I take your
order
listen the fact of the matter is that I
need a pepperoni pizza
why are you screaming let's be clear
about this I'm serious let's be clear
Barack and I had pizza every night I
invented pizza I passed the legislation
that makes it possible for you people to
eat pizza I'm serious
that's that's Joe Biden's answer to
every single question let's be clear I'm
serious
Barack listen and the fact of the matter
that's every it's just it's a
combination of those words screamed and
of course in Bernie's case not only does
he scream every answer but he's also
incapable of uttering a sentence that
doesn't include the word billionaire now
we know he used to have a lot more range
in his vocabulary because he used to
talk about millionaires and billionaires
so he used to have two words he could
say but then he became a millionaire and
so he doesn't want to rail against
millionaires anymore because he is won
and so now it's just Billy now he's now
he's limited to just one word his method
of arguing is to accuse anyone who
disagrees with him of being a
billionaire which is very similar to the
general sort of left-wing method of
arguing where normally they accuse
anyone who disagrees with them of being
a Nazi
now Bernie's not you know not opposed to
using that method but he prefers that
for him to be a billionaires worse than
being a Nazi
so his comeback to everything always is
oh yeah did the billionaire's pay you to
say that and then he waits for the
applause although last night it was
interesting that the audience seemed to
be stacked against him so every time he
went for the billionaire comeback the
billionaire diss it got solicited boos
in the audience which was interesting
but probably my favorite thing from
Bernie last night
was when he attempted to reach out to
minority communities by promising to
help them sell drugs and that really did
happen that's that's something that he
really did and we'll play that clip for
you in just a moment but first let's
check in with our good friends over at
Rock Auto you know the thing that always
impresses me about rockauto.com when I
go to their website which I go
frequently for for our various car
problems which we frequently have is
just the selection that they that they
have that have it seems seemingly
everything you could possibly need and
it's extremely easy to navigate
you know chain stores the thing
about the chain stores you go there they
have different price tiers for
professional mechanics and
do-it-yourselfers they're gonna decide
you know based on your experience level
how much they're gonna charge you well
rockauto.com doesn't do that same price
for every but doesn't even require
membership or account or anything to
login you just go there you get what you
need rockauto.com always offers the
lowest price as possible rather than
changing price tiers based on what the
market will bear and so they're just
gonna give you a low prices great
selection and that's it that's what
you're getting the rockauto.com catalog
is unique remarkably easy to navigate
rocket or comma is everything from
engine control modules and brake parts
to tail lamps and motor oil and even new
carpet whatever you could possibly need
they've got it there so go to
rockauto.com right now see all the parts
available for your car or truck that's
Rock Auto calm right Walsh in there how
did you hear about us box so that they
know that I sent you
alright so Bernie Sanders was was trying
to appeal to minority communities and
and his attempt to appeal to them was by
promising that he would help them sell
drugs listen to this and I'll tell you
what else we're gonna do we're gonna
provide help to the african-american
Latino Native American community to
start businesses to sell legal marijuana
rather than let a few corporations
control the legalized marijuana market
yes that is that's Bernie's minority
outreach he's gonna he's gonna let them
sell their drugs now okay I know the
Democrats get the advantage of a double
standard on racial issues and on all
other issues of course but how is that
not the most racist thing that any
candidate has said through this entire
election cycle and beyond the that's
when he thinks of helping you know young
black people and and and Hispanics that
asian-americans are this is what this is
what comes to mind this would be like if
he said he wanted to help the Irish
American community he has a great plan
for helping them and and it is he's
gonna offer half-off discounts on all we
skee that's his plan to reach out to
Irish Americans which as an Irish
American I would very much appreciate
that especially as I'm you know we're
trying to stock up all the necessary
provisions for the coronavirus and it's
very important by the way that you're
prepared for that you have all the
whiskey you're gonna need to get through
it in case there is any disruptions in
the in the supply chain of whiskey or if
you can't get to the store but so I
would appreciate that but still I mean
it's it we can't deny it's pretty
demeaning but of course the gaff that
everyone is talking about tonight is or
today is is Biden making a rather
startling claim about gun violence
listen to this but my friend am i right
and others have in fact also gave in to
the gun manufacturers absolute immunity
imagine if I stood here and said we give
immunity to drug companies we give
immunity tobacco companies that is
caused carnage on our streets a hundred
and fifty million people have been
killed since 2007 when Bernie voted to
exempt the gun manufacturers from
liability more than all the wars
including Vietnam from that point on
carnage on our street not want to tell
you if I'm elected enter I'm coming for
you and gun manufacturers I'm gonna take
you out 150 million people have died
from gun violence in the past 13 years
that was the claim 150 million people
that's that's half of the US population
so what I learned last night is that
half of the US population is currently
dead from gun violence which I guess the
the bright side of that I mean if there
can be a bright side to 150 million
people dying the bright side is that now
fewer people will die from climate
change
so when climate change kills us all in
10 years or 9 years or whatever it is
now there's just the devastation will in
some ways be lessened by the fact that
most of us will have already died from
being shot so I mean I look I'm trying
to find a silver lining around that
cloud and that's the best I could do now
Elizabeth Warren here's something that
stood out to me she
she launched into an attack on Bloomberg
and this seems to be her main focus is
attacking Bloomberg for some reason even
though Bloomberg hasn't won hasn't even
contested it hasn't even been in the
contest yet for any of any of the
primaries up to this point but she's
very focused on Bloomberg but there's
something about this this moment that
really stood out to me watch to watch
this you know this is personal for me
when I was 21 years old I got my first
job as a special education teacher I
loved that job and by the end of the
first year I was visibly pregnant the
principal wished me luck and gave my job
to someone else
pregnancy discrimination you bet but I
was 21 years old I didn't have a union
to protect me and I didn't have any
federal law on my side so I packed up my
stuff and I went home at least I didn't
have a boss who said to me kill it the
way that I mare Bloomberg never read
that said to wanna [ __ ] come on pregnant
employ okay now of course the story
she's telling there about pregnancy
discrimination is bogus of course it's
been debunked like almost everything
else she says she's a pathological liar
she can't help herself she lies it's a
compulsion she can't she can't stop
herself from doing it she lies like she
breathes but that's not that's not the
part that was interested me at the end
of the clip there she accuses Bloomberg
of telling a pregnant mother to kill it
being the baby now I don't know if
Bloomberg said that or not he denies it
who knows sounds a little far-fetched
but but maybe he said it that's not the
point here's my question why does she
have a problem Warren that is with
somebody suggesting that a woman kill
her baby
Warren is radically pro-abortion in fact
radically Pro infanticide as we'll talk
about in a few minutes from her
perspective the baby is not human has no
right to life has no dignity has no
moral value has no value of any kind
why shouldn't Bloomberg say kill it
what's the problem what exactly is the
issue I mean you know I know what the
problem is of course hopefully you know
what the problem is but then again
against killing babies in general so of
course I can be against that about
against what he said allegedly but
Warren is in favor of it not just in
favor of it but she believes that
killing babies is not just that it's
okay but that it's a liberating act it's
a it's a it's an expression of a woman's
autonomy and independence
so all Bloomberg was really suggesting
is that a work that is that this woman
express her autonomy and independence
he didn't say kill it he said express
your autonomy it was empowering it was a
it was an empowering encouragement to
this woman not to be enslaved by the the
subhuman parasite in her body from
Warren's perspective that's what it was
see but it's it's hard to be consistent
to be intellectually consistent when
you're pro-abortion because it means
that you have no basis no reason to get
upset about something like what
Bloomberg is alleged to have said but at
the same time you know that what he said
allegedly is cruel and awful so you want
to be against it you want to be outraged
by it but you can't be because to be
outraged by it is to admit that killing
babies is a moral outrage which is
exactly what you cannot admit speaking
of morally outrageous Bernie Sanders
last night was again stumbling and
bumbling around trying to justify all
their if they're very nice and admiring
things that he said about communist
regimes like the one in Cuba or the one
that was in communist or Soviet Russia
so I want to play a clip for you
not from last night but from the night
before at a town hall on CNN where he's
again going into the wonders of
communist governments and then we'll
talk about it watch this the response
was the one Fidel Castro first came to
power which was when 59 sat-sun 29 60
okay you know what he did he initiated a
major literacy program was a lot of a
lot of folks in Cuba at that point
who
literate and he formed the literacy
brigade you may remember read that they
went out and they help people learn to
read and write you know what I think
teaching people to read and write is a
good thing I have been extremely
consistent and critical of all
authoritarian regimes all over the world
including Cuba including Nicaragua
including Saudi Arabia including China
including Russia I happen to believe in
democracy not authoritarianism but you
know you can't say China is another
example all right China is an
authoritarian country becoming more and
more authoritarian but can anyone deny I
mean the facts are clear that they have
taken more people out of extreme poverty
than any country in history well I get
criticized because I say that it that's
the truth
so that is the fact and they'll discuss
so end of discussion he says not really
we will discuss what he said in a moment
but first checking in with expressvpn
you know it seems to me that using the
internet without a VPN it's a bit like
going to the bathroom without closing
the door which if if you're like me and
you live through most of your early 20s
by yourself and you got very used to
doing that but then once there's other
people around you can't do it anymore
it's it's you're exposing yourself why
would you allow yourself to be exposed
in that way well that's what it's like
when you use the internet without a VPN
did you know that your internet service
provider knows every single website you
visit whether it's Comcast or Verizon
whoever you use they know everything
about you basically they know all of
your internet activity and what's worse
is they can sell this information to ad
companies and tech giants who will use
your data to target you so you're being
exploited as well as exposed and all of
your private information is out there
expressvpn puts a stop to this it
creates a secure encrypted tunnel
between your device and the Internet so
that your online activity can't be seen
by anyone expressvpn works on everything
phones laptops routers so everyone who
shares your Wi-Fi can still be protected
even if they don't have expressvpn best
part is using expressvpn isn't as easy
as is closing the bathroom door it's
just it's that simple
so if you're like me and you believe
that your online activity is your
business you should have that privacy
secure yourself by visiting expressvpn
comm slash walls today use my exclusive
link that's exp ress VPN dot-com slash
walsh you get an extra three months for
free if you use that URL that's
expressvpn comm slash walsh okay
so Bernie extolling the virtues of
communist regimes
first of all those literacy programs
so-called war really region programs but
even if Castro did help people be more
literate he also locked political
dissidents in prison he executed people
who opposed him he starved his own
people
it was tyranny it was oppression so
saying yeah but literacy it is no
different is no different at all than
saying yeah but they had good policies
protecting animal rights in reference to
Nazi Nazi Germany which in fact the
Nazis did they they were very much into
animal welfare not so much into human
welfare but they loved animals at least
but of course making that argument would
sound morally obtuse in the extreme this
is the same thing here's what I would
recommend I'm gonna talk more about this
tomorrow because I want I want to move
on from politics right now but but
tomorrow or the next day I want to well
get more into this what I'll say for now
is I know I have a book out and I'm
urging you to read it so I don't want to
give you too many things to read but my
book is not that long so you can get
through that once you do that my next
suggestion is to get a book that's a lot
longer
it's called Gulag Archipelago by
Solzhenitsyn it's three volumes each
volume is probably about 900 pages or so
start with the first volume read that at
least this should be required reading
for kids in high school and it should be
required reading for everybody if you
want to know what communism is what it's
really like if you want to know what the
real cost is for all the wonderful
literacy programs and everything else
all that all the supposedly good things
that communism allegedly brings then
this book a book that of course was
banned in Soviet Russia so so much for
literacy
the book is Solzhenitsyn's history of
the Soviet labor camp system he
intertwines his own experience in it
because he was sent to the labor camps
so it's his own story it's sort of a
memoir slash general history of of
Soviet Russia and the labor camp system
and it's gripping it's absorbing it's
fascinating it's brutal to read and it's
important especially now as America
threatens to elect a communist president
by the way do you know why
Solzhenitsyn went to prison because he
fought in World War two for the Soviets
he was Russian and Stalin had a system
back then of sending many of the boys
who and they were boys a lot of them
young younger than eighteen who were off
fighting the war and and and these were
the guys who had seen some of the most
brutal and and bloodiest some of the
worst fighting in the war after they'd
gone through that for the sake of their
country there thank you when they got
home was many of them were shipped off
to labor camps why is that because
Stalin was was worried that they'd been
exposed to Western ideas and so he felt
threatened by that and to play it safe
he just sent a lot of them off to the
labor camps Solzhenitsyn was sent off
because he had written a letter while he
was on the front written a couple
letters where he was vaguely critical of
the government and that was intercepted
and seen and he went to the labor camp
system for that I would just start
reading that book and there's no way I
mean there's no way you could get even
halfway through it and still have any
positive thoughts about communism we'll
talk more about this that this week
because there's a lot in that book that
I think is is very instructive and it's
a book that you know maybe maybe Bernie
Sanders should get around to reading at
some point alright let's let's check in
with some some news we'll go through
five headlines here that are worth
knowing about number one the CDC is now
warning that an outbreak of the corona
virus in the US is inevitable and we
should prepare for significant
disruptions to our daily life that's
that's the words they're using
we're told quote it's not so much a
question of if this will happen in this
country anymore but a question of when
this will happen now I've been a skeptic
up until now I've I've seen the media
hype up these epidemics many times I've
seen so much unnecessary panic over so
many things that I thought this was
another one of those things it appears I
may have been wrong this is the time
when you know the boy crying wolf
the boys crying wolf and maybe there
actually is a wolf this time now I still
think there's no need to panic I still
think we should keep in mind that the
death toll of this virus has a lot to do
with the fact that it started in China
where their health care system is
falling apart I mean their hospitals are
literally falling apart or in shambles
so we're basing the the the death toll
on that the mortality rate we're basing
on that and so I think that's something
we should keep in mind it's also true
though that the CDC doesn't generally
stay stuff like this for no reason so
perhaps it would make sense to take some
precautions in fact my wife last night
we were talking about this and she
started buying supplies we both agreed
that you know maybe you get if the CDC
is saying there may be some disruptions
to your daily life
maybe disruptions in the supply chain
there's you know for you're not able to
get out of the house if there's
quarantines or something that it makes
sense to have some preservable food and
stuff like that in the house so my wife
my wife was buying a few things she
started buying freeze-dried meats and I
you know I said to her why why can't we
get regular meat and freeze it and she
said because we have an extra freezer in
the garage and she said well if the
power goes out and I said why would the
coronavirus cause the power to go out
and she didn't really have a response
for that but that didn't dissuade her so
she got all that I guess we're now
preparing for the end of human
civilization as we know it
which for the record I still insist that
human civilization is not coming to an
end over this but a little preparation
is probably smart okay number two a
video that's gone viral out of the
hellscape known as San Francisco shows a
black man stealing cans from and
attempting to assault an Asian man while
a group of people stand around laughing
and the guy filming cheers and on and
says I hate Asians watch this now I'm
just looking forward to hearing from the
only white people can be racist crowd on
this one I'm sure they can explain how
what you just saw there is not racist
I'm sure they have a great explanation
it can't be because this is what we're
told
Oh a black person cannot be racist by
definition so what you saw they're not
racist
somehow three yesterday Michelle
Genovese who the media tells us is the
hotpokket heiress the heir to the
hotpocket fortune was sentenced to five
months in jail for the college
admissions scandal she apparently spent
hundreds of thousands of dollars
helping her daughter's cheat on contests
defrauding colleges and other ways I
think she had one of her daughters and a
fake somehow a fake fake volleyball
scholarship or something like that
in order to get them into into good
schools and now she's going to prison
for it
not really prison I'm sure the place
she's going will be more of a more of a
sleepaway camp than a prison I think a
better penalty a harsher one would be to
force her to eat only hot pockets for
breakfast lunch and dinner for say a
year if you can even survive that
because of course it's not technically
edible this isn't really it's not a real
food product I don't know what it is but
it's not food certainly the roof of her
mouth would be destroyed by the end of
it
with those gushes of molten cheese just
scorching her mouth at every meal cruel
and unusual punishment I suppose number
four a conservative think-tank has found
who they're calling the anti Greta you
know Greta Thune burger of course the
sixteen-year-old climate alarmists
that's all over the media well a
conservative think-tank went out and
fine
found their own blonde teenage girl but
this one is a skeptic of climate change
and now they're sending her out to make
the case against climate alarmism
she's a nineteen year old German named
Naomi so this is great this is really
great right conservatives have been
saying for months that we shouldn't
listen to teenagers on science that
teens are not science experts and we
were right about that you know it's
silly to use teenagers as as mascots on
an issue like this and now what are we
doing I guess we're turning around and
finding our own teenage fake science
expert here's an idea here's here's a
different option maybe we should
consider this maybe we could stop
propping teenagers up as experts in
anything
maybe liberals could stop doing it
conservatives can stop doing it
because teenagers don't know anything
they're not experts in anything they
aren't authorities in anything and if
you as an adult are turning to a
teenager for a wisdom or insight into
any subject at all especially science
that is a symptom of your own rather
staggering mental deficiencies I mean if
you have ever heard a teenager say
something particularly on the issue of
you know in the realm of science and
thought yourself wow that's I learned
something today I never thought of that
before that tells you a lot more about
you than it does about them so maybe we
could just stop doing this
number five ABC is now working on a
Bachelor spin-off this one for senior
citizens the casting call on the website
says now casting seniors looking for
love are you entering your golden years
and looking for romance the producers of
The Bachelor are looking for active and
outgoing single men and women in their
golden years
new exciting dating show I have to be
honest with you I have never seen one
second of The Bachelor or any of its
variants I have no idea what the show
even is I've always beg Lea wondered
what happens on it I've never cared
enough to investigate so I guess women
are competing to commit to be the one
who gets to marry a guy a random guy is
that what it is is the guy is he rich or
something what's the why is it a prize
well anyway speaking of mental
deficiencies I I don't see how anyone
with an IQ over save 45 could watch a
show like this but then when you
consider the high ratings these shows
get you know that's a whole lot of sub
45 IQs out there and these people can
vote too and if you can imagine and that
explains a lot about our about the state
of our republic I have said many times
and I do believe that I would be in
favor of automatically disenfranchising
anyone who has ever watched an entire
episode of a show like The Bachelor you
lose your voting rights permanently I
would be totally in favor of that if
only a candidate would have the guts to
suggest a policy of that sort but of
course no candidate would do that
because every political candidate they
love the idea of dumb people voting
because dumb people are a lot a lot
easier to to manipulate all right um so
moving on on Tuesday Democrats in the US
Senate blocked a bill that would have
required clinics and hospitals to
provide basic medical treatment to
infants born alive after botched
abortions Democrats tried to position
the born alive abortions survivor
Protection Act which is what it was
called started positioning it as a
radical assault on the bodily autonomy
of women an intrusion of the government
into medical decisions but it was
nothing of a sort of course you can read
the text of the bill despite the
histrionics and the claims from people
like Senator Gillibrand who went on CNN
and said that the legislation would harm
women despite all that all the act would
have done
is prohibit abortionists from leaving
infant children to die after they're
born after a failed abortion there is no
clump of cells dodge available here the
humans in question are infant children
born fully developed living breathing
outside the womb Democrats have now
declared that even they aren't worthy of
legal protections even they apparently
have no moral value now as always the
pro and vanta side infanticide democrats
have the full support of the media so
CNN with no hint of irony actually in an
article yesterday called babies born
after abortions fetuses I believe the
phrase they used was it was a fetus that
was born
that's a baby that survives an abortion
a fetus that was born and they
distinguish in the article they
distinguish the fetus that was born from
a newborn baby they're saying those are
two different things according to CNN a
newborn baby is a child that's born
alive on purpose because the mother
wants the child and a fetus that was
born is a is a is a child that was born
accidentally despite the wishes of the
mother so the humanity of the baby even
outside of the womb depends entirely on
the mother's desires and this is what
pro-abortion people have been saying for
a long time they've been very explicit
about it if you ask them and you say
well when does life begin they'll say
life begins when the mother wants the
the humanity of the child is relative to
the mother's wishes and desires and now
we're being told that that logic extends
even beyond the womb now it's it's was
argued that this bill was unnecessary
because babies so rarely managed to
survive abortions so it's just an
unnecessary bill we don't need to do
this well if that's true then first of
all why oppose it and why claim that
it's an attack on women's rights so you
can't have it both ways either it's an
unnecessary
redundant bill or it's it's a a terrible
assault on on the the rights of women or
neither of those things of course that
it's neither of those but it can't be
both of those things and in any case if
the claim is not true this does happen
hundreds of children have died after
surviving abortion attempts and that's
those are just the ones we know about
because there are only a few states that
per that report that kind of information
and even there you're relying on the
abortion clinics to honestly report what
happened so just based on the very
limited sample that we know about it's
clear that it has happened hundreds of
times so those are hundreds of infant
children who were left to die and could
have been saved
the current law does not protect those
babies now the current law does
allegedly prevent abortionists from
actively killing the babies who are born
after a botched abortion although we
know that even that happens Kermit
Gosnell did it for decades killed
hundreds of babies directly and was able
to do it for decades in the middle of
anim jur American city without being
stopped but allegedly the law stops out
but the law does not require that
doctors you know hospitals clinics
provide basic medical treatment to the
babies so what they can do is just set
the baby aside and let the child die and
that is what they do in fact do and now
can continue doing it's also worth
noting that Democrats blocked a bill
yesterday also that would have that
would have outlawed abortion after 20
weeks gestation babies at that point can
feel pain at 22 weeks they can survive
outside the womb now of course nobody's
surprised by that move we knew that they
would they would block that bill but it
underscores the point that the Democrat
Party at this point is nothing more than
a [ __ ] of the abortion industry that's
what it is it is
morally corrupted and evil to its core
it is an enemy of life and of dignity
and if you are a decent person
you just cannot associate yourself with
it you can't be a Democrat you can't
vote for Democrats if you're a decent
person who cares about human life and
dignity I'm not saying you have to be a
Republican not at all
it's just you can't be a Democrat though
all right now for today's daily
cancellation it is my great pleasure in
fact to cancel the New Yorker
the New York of today posted a cartoon
on Twitter that is leading to me now
canceling The New Yorker and when I said
Cannes I don't mean canceling my own
subscription I don't have a subscribe
I'm saying that the New Yorker in
general is cancelled now by decree by me
so take a look at this at this cartoon
if you're listening on itunes can't see
it it's it's a four-panel comic the
first panel shows a guy in the
wilderness and he says oh no it's
getting cold and dark in the next panel
he sees another guy Mark Zuckerberg and
he says thank God another hiker hiker
Mark Zuckerberg can you help I'm lost
then Zuckerberg says ok and then
Zuckerberg says here are a few options
one of them is accurate the others could
be misinformation I'll let you decide
and then in the final panel you see his
helicopters like a Bruce helicopter in
the background and he says well this is
me by which that part is kind of funny
and then I guess he leaves the guy he's
the guy in the in the wilderness as he
as he goes away in his helicopter now
the point here is rather rather obvious
this is a criticism of Facebook's
refusal to do fact checks on political
ads and on other content and and and
their refusal to disallow the content
that is not in their opinion truthful
the left thinks that Facebook should be
performing this kind of fact-checking
function on the content mainly because
the left hopes and assumes that a
Facebook does fact checks all of the
right-wing content all the pro Trump
Trump content all that stuff will sue
merrily be banned because all of that is
false they think so in this analogy we
the helpless social media consumer the
average Facebook user we are like
Wanderers in a cold wilderness fearful
lost darkness is closing in and Mike
Mark Zuckerberg is that is the guide who
can show us the way into the light and
the warmth and that is apparently how
the New Yorker sees our relationship to
billionaire tech mogul z-- which is very
interesting they see the billionaire
tech mogul as this as this this guide in
the wilderness that can save our lives
we must cling to them show me the way
Mark Zuckerberg that's how they see them
yet they they hate billionaires they
think billionaires are evil but they
also want billionaires to decide what's
true and not true and to moderate our
access to content according to their the
billionaires opinions about what's true
and not true so they hate billionaires
but they also see billionaires as the
only ones who can rescue us from certain
death in the forest of confusion now
this is all nonsensical of course it is
not Facebook's job to decide what
content is true it's not their job to
evaluate political ads or political
content for its adherence to the truth
why would you trust Facebook with that
task why would you trust Facebook any
more than you would trust whoever
created the content to begin with I'm
not saying you should automatically
trust either one you shouldn't that's
the point yes you should make up your
own mind so in this case in this
particular wilderness of the Internet's
yeah you should be given options and you
can make up your own mind you you
shouldn't want the billionaire in the
helicopter to rescue you and make it
easy in fact when it comes to
deciphering this stuff you know and
deciding what's true and not true it is
better for the hiker to make up his own
mind
because the other option is to trust
Mark Zuckerberg blindly and to go
wherever he points and that would be
foolish
so this is a very dumb cartoon
and a very not just a dumb point but one
that contradicts what we normally hear
from places like The New Yorker and that
is why the New Yorker is now canceled
all right um got a bunch of email also I
think we'll save this email for tomorrow
so people chiming in on the issue of
student loans challenging my position
that I expressed yesterday which is that
in when looking for the villains in the
story of the student debt crisis I think
one of the primary villains are the
employers who have created in many ways
this artificial need for degrees and
anyway a lot of people disagree with me
on that and I'll read those emails
tomorrow Matt Walsh show at gmail.com
Matt Walsh show at gmail.com we'll wrap
it up there thanks for watching
everybody
Church of cowards and stores now
Godspeed
the Matt Walsh show is produced by Sean
Hampton executive producer Jeremy boring
supervising producer Mathis Glover
supervising producer Robert Stirling
technical producer austin stevens editor
danny D'Amico audio mixer robin
Fenderson the Matt Walsh show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
20 hey everybody its Andrew Clavin host
of the Andrew Clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
American Republic is collapsing the end
of days is approaching and the moon has
turned to blood but on the Andrew Clavin
show that's where the fun just gets
started so come on over to the Andrew
Clavin show and laugh your way through
the apocalypse with me Andrew clip
[Music]